Welcome back, everyone.
We have a first look at Marvel's Agatha
Coven of Chaos.
They started filming,
so there's a bunch of scenes
that dropped, so we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs,
and it's the return of Billy Wilkins.
So I'll explain what's going on,
because supposedly he's
going to be a huge part of the plot and
what's going on with the villain group.
If you bring it to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're also doing a giveaway for me
and the wasp Quantumania tickets
because that movie is coming out so soon.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with Wicked inside the MCU.
I know everybody's
hyped about the young Avengers.
Everyone's like,
What are they going to do, young Avengers?
When are they going to bring that team
together?
They will be using this series
to help set up Young Avengers.
I'll explain how that's going to work
because we'll also see teasers for that
during Man of the wasp Quantumania.
Thanks to our sponsor for this episode
Skillshare.
This year, Supercharge Your Creativity
with Skillshare is online classes.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning,
with so much to explore real projects
to create in the support of fellow
creatives, Skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth.
I've been learning about writing scripts
because it's a huge part
of making YouTube videos.
If you want to learn
how to make better YouTube videos
or how to make your audio sound better,
like how do I make my YouTube videos
sound better?
You might be interested in video
editing or Photoshop or audio
production in no matter what
skill it is that you want to learn.
There is definitely a class for it
on Skillshare.
I've been using a lot of the Adobe
Photoshop training courses in the past
and it was a great way
to get very condensed guides on how to use
the more technical aspects of Photoshop.
They come in handy every day.
Skillshare is also incredibly affordable,
especially compared to the price
of in-person classes in workshops.
The annual subscription is less than $10
a month To explore
your creativity at Skillshare dot
com slash emergency.
They're currently running a free 30 day
trial for premium membership.
You can click on the link
in the description
or use the one on screen here.
It's Skillshare dotcom slash emergency,
so be sure to check it out.
So in the New scenes,
we see Agatha Harkness at the Westview
Mall with Billy Kaplan, who's going to be
the Billy Caplan persona,
at least at the beginning of the series
before we learn what's really going on.
But the character Billy Caplan,
is really technically, quote unquote,
Billy Maximoff, played by Joe Locke here.
He's the one that was posting
a lot of these clips, these pictures.
So many thanks to him.
If you zoom in, enhanced on this one
scene of them
walking through the mall here,
you can see the QR code in the background
with the message.
It says be an insider
that's meant to be another
one of their huge Easter eggs
with a QR code that they've been doing
in all the series they did
in all the She-Hulk episodes.
They've done it in a bunch of the other
Marvel Disney Plus series
where you scan the QR code
and you can get free comics.
Let me know in the comments
which free comics
you think they're giving away with these
QR codes in the Agatha episodes?
Maybe some Agatha Harkness specific
comics, maybe some young Avengers.
Billy Caplan Specific comics.
You see Agatha at the regular Westview
Mall with him eating snacks, talking
as if it's a normal day
in the neighborhood.
She's dressed in
contemporary casual clothing.
It doesn't look too goth out,
which means she might still be in
full blown Agnes mode when this happens
under Scarlet Witch's spell.
In this different scene,
there's a Westview police car,
which seems like it's
part of the larger mystery
that Agatha uncovers as she's slowly
remembering what Scarlet
Witch did to her with the spell
and uncovering the plot to steal Billy,
The working title of the series is there
filming is Mayor of Westview in the font.
The title are meant to be a joke.
Easter Eggs for the mayor of Easttown,
which is a crime drama starring
Kate Winslet about a detective
investigating a murder in a sleepy town,
uncovering all kinds of spicy details
and secrets about the inhabitants
while she tries to keep her own life
from falling apart.
There's more to give you an idea
for the vibe of the show
Now, obviously,
there's going to be more comedy
happening in this Agatha series
than what's happening in Mare of Easttown.
That was more of a serious drama.
But during the series, Agatha Harkness
is the main character.
She's the protagonist.
They're playing her
like more of a straight up
anti-hero, trying to help Billy Kaplan
protect him from Morgan, let's say,
and find out why they want him.
Her rogue coven of witches in the larger
machinations of Mephisto at play
because reportedly he's
going to play a role during the series,
like they'll actually finally pay off
some of these Mephisto jokes
if you didn't see the last couple
of years.
Reportedly, Sacha Baron
Cohen has been filming different scenes
as a version of MCU Mephisto
for different upcoming series.
Surprisingly, the first series
that were supposed to see him
during or that he'll be tied to
will be the iron Heart Series,
because that series is all
about the battle
between magic and technology,
like the balance of magic and technology.
Agatha Harkness is also supposed
to be connected to that too, but
I think they'll explain it's separate
from what happened with her versus Scarlet
Witch and being put under the spell again
after Scarlet Witch took off.
The Hood is going to be one of the main
villains of the series,
and he'll be going up against Ironheart,
supposedly Anthony Ramos,
who the character is
the apprentice of Agatha Harkness,
and Mephisto will be loosely involved
pulling strings from behind the scenes.
I don't think he's supposed to be
a major character during that series.
The Agatha Coven of Chaos series will
take place after the events of Ironheart.
I think they'll just explain that he's
continuing
to pull strings from behind the scenes.
But the main idea during
the series is the main
part of the story is Agatha
trying to keep Aubrey Plaza as character.
Morgan Lafe in her coven of witches
away from Billie, played by Joe Locke.
Here.
Morgan Le Fay's rogue coven supposedly
is the one that's connected to Mephisto
in the whole idea at the end of West.
Do you like the big teaser here?
When Agatha told Scarlet Witch,
You're going to need me for
what's coming,
you have no idea what you've done.
You have no idea what you've unleashed.
You're going to need me.
If, I do.
I know where to find you. Wait.
That was tied more to what's happening
with the multiverse.
Avengers five, Qing Dynasty,
The collapse of the multiverse.
All these incursions sort started
teasing during Marvel Phase four.
Like during Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness with other larger
magical beings like Mephisto
taking advantage of the chaos.
Like right now.
I think the idea is that
Mephisto is still trapped
in his own dimension and seeking a way
into the main MCU dimension.
They tease that a little bit during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
When they were traveling
through the multiverse,
they traveled through one of the hell
dimensions
were pretty much the entirety of New York.
Like this entire
reality had turned into a version of hell,
like everything is on fire.
Part of the idea is that
Mephisto wants to take over the main MCU
dimension like all the other higher beings
across the Marvel multiverse.
And it sounds like based on the plot
he's trying to use, Morgan Lopez Coven,
whether they know it or not,
to take Billy for himself, use his power
to take over the main MCU dimension.
Because if it wasn't clear
from all the Wandavision
episodes, Billy has basically
the same types of powers in Scarlet Witch.
Like he can warp reality.
He's meant to be an incredibly powerful
magic user.
And just like in the young Avengers
comics, Billy is destined
to become the next demiurge,
this omnipotent, magical being basically
like on the level
of what you would expect.
Scarlet Witch is powers to be like this
multiverse level power
that could theoretically change
control of the entire universe.
It sounds like if they're actually
using Mephisto as part of this series,
that's why he really wants Bill.
Like that's the real reason
in the same reason why Morgan,
the Phase coven want him to like
they would want him for his power.
It just sounds like if they are using
Mephisto, he's actually playing everyone,
like he's lending them some power,
but also really trying to play them
during the series.
They also will address
what happened to Scarlet Witch.
Like there's this big rumor
going around the magic mutiny in the MCU.
The Scarlet Witch has died
and they'll start to explore that.
And at some point during the series,
we will see the new origin of Billy
and Tommy being reincarnated
into the bodies of Billy Kaplan
and Tommy Shepherd
like we saw in the comics.
So the way they explain Billy and Tommy's
backstory in the MCU is super confusing.
A couple of different writers worked on it
across a bunch of different years.
They tried to make sense
of all that continuity.
A little more recently.
In the past, Scarlet Witch learned
that her children were fake.
We saw a version of that
during the One Division series.
Like she understood that she created her
children with a fake version of vision.
Then when she took the hex down,
her children were destroyed with it.
We saw alternate realities
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
where versions of them were still alive.
So we know that they are still out there
somewhere.
But in the main 616 MCU universe,
they're reincarnated
magically into the bodies of Billy Kaplan
and Tommy Sheppard,
and they become Wiccan and speed
as part of the young Avengers eventually.
So couple of the big things
that they're using
the Agatha series to set up
are the formal return of Scarlet Witch.
Like we know that she's coming back.
That's not going to happen until Avengers
five Qing Dynasty,
but also set up young Avengers
with Billy and Tommy.
We've only seen footage of what
seems like the new adult version of Billy.
I haven't seen any Tommy footage yet,
but we're supposed to get our first teaser
for The Young Avengers during Amy
and the wasp Quantumania.
It's supposed to have a young Avengers
Post-Credits scene teaser.
Like one of the Post-Credits
scenes will be Cassie Lang
teasing the formation
of the Young Avengers,
but I don't think they're actually going
to come together
as a team with all the characters they've
been introducing for a couple of years.
Probably not until after Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty and Secret Wars,
like not till Marvel Phase seven,
just because there's
a lot of conflicting reports
about when the Agatha Coven of Chaos
episodes are going to be released.
Originally, they were going to try
at the end of this year.
Then it was pushed
like the beginning of 2024.
Now there's talk about delaying it
to early 2025.
So just charting the timeline.
If you look at the Marvel Phase
six schedule here, Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty is supposed to come out
in spring of 2025
if they don't release Agatha
Coven of Chaos episodes two,
like the beginning of that year, like
right before Avengers five, Qing Dynasty
and they're still just barely introducing
young Avengers characters,
like teasing that, Oh, eventually, someday
we'll come together and form the team.
Then it's
probably still a couple of years away
at the beginning of 2025, which puts it
well into Marvel Phase seven.
Maybe we'll see a couple of the characters
start coming together before that though,
and with them setting up the return
of Scarlet Witch like the actual physical
return in Avengers five Qing Dynasty,
it sounds like they'll be doing more
Scarlet Witch crossovers with the X-Men
in Marvel Phase seven and beyond.
That was one of the things Elizabeth
Olsen said that she wanted to do that
they had not been able to do yet, like
she wanted to do more X-Men crossovers
in a lot of Marvel Phase
seven and beyond will be like really hard
core X-Men stuff.
Also sounds like a whole bunch
of young Avengers
stuff
to let me know in the comments though.
What else do you want them to do
during Agatha Coven of Chaos?
Like,
obviously Agatha is going to continue
to be a big character in Marvel
going forward,
but essentially it's
kind of like a sequel to Wandavision.
Most of the characters, like the normal
townspeople that starred in Wandavision,
will be coming back
during Agatha Coven of Chaos.
It's just like normal
townspeople in Westview,
and it sounds like at least
the first couple of episodes,
or maybe just the first episode
will tease the same thing that happened
at the beginning of Wandavision,
where, like, Agatha slowly wakes up to
the reality of what's actually going on.
Like, Wait a minute,
why is everything so weird?
Oh, wait a minute.
That's right.
Because I'm Agatha Harkness
and I'm super powerful, and we'll see her
slowly breaking free of Scarlet
Witch's enchantment while she uncovers
this larger mystery with Morgan Lafe
and what's happening with Billy Kaplan
because they're filming, will be getting
a whole bunch more footage real soon.
So of course they'll do more videos
as we get more scenes.
If you have any big questions
about what's going on during the series
or like other big Marvel Phase
five Marvel Phase
six stuff, just write it
below in the comments.
We're going to get a whole bunch of big
Super Bowl trailers.
The next big Marvel series
is going to be Secret Invasion.
Of course,
they'll be doing episode videos for that,
just like all the other big Marvel Disney
Plus series.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for my full Last of Us
Episode 2 Video and Easter Eggs
and click here for my brand new Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.